the thing that is killing most of you
guys is the desire to 10x in 90 days and
then not doing it and trying something
new and hoping for a silver bullet That
Never Comes it's just it's 100 golden
bbb's like the big businesses is just
improving lots of little things over and
over again the 40% Improvement that Jim
lch has had since we sold our majority
share there's been no one thing we just
improved a lot of little things and that
creates the big outcome and so right now
you probably have this big list of
should do if you actually just wrote all
the things that you need to do down and
then you tick them off and you realize
that it takes 2 years to build an
exceptional business and you did nothing
but just actually do all the you
know you should be doing you usually
build a pretty exceptional business it's
the rush that kills everyone it's the
hope that this new thing is somehow
going to shortcut the work that needs to
be done and so the faster you can
confront the work that has to get done
the FAS you start getting the getting